juste une question à laquelle je n'ai
pas eu de réponse et je me permets
d'insister là-dessus parce que je vous
avoue qu'il s'envolait beaucoup surpris
ainsi que de nombreux collègues je vous
ai posé la question est-ce que l'un ou
l'autre vous êtes allé à Saint-Brévin
pour témoigner le soutien de l'État au
maire de Saint-Brévin ce qui nous avait
surpris et qui m'avait moi
personnellement heurté c'est d'apprendre
que l'un ou l'autre était allé à Pornic
48 heures après l'incendie pour aller à
Pornic il faut obligatoirement passer
par Saint-Brevin et personne n'avait
pris le soin de s'arrêter à Saint-Brevin
qui a 15 à 20 minutes je regardais sur
Mappy itinéraire ni à l'aller ni au
retour pour rendre visite au maire de
Saint-Brevin et ça je ne le comprends
pas
je rappelle qu'à ce moment-là ça se
passe deux jours après
l'incendie des véhicules
j'ai eu le maire le jour de l'incendie
je n'ai pas perçu de demande
particulière de sa part à ce moment-là
peut-être à tort
semble-t-il à tort mais et je voulais
indiquer compte tenu du vous connaissez
les habitudes en matière d'inauguration
il y a souvent les maires des environs
qui sont qui sont invités le maire de la
de la communauté le président de la
communauté de communes pouvait être
invité et je pensais qu'il était j'étais
un peu étonné qu'il ne le soit pas
présent mais
j'ai pas ensuite eu le réflexe de
l'appeler pour lui dire je viens je
viens chez vous c'est exact
bien
oui Monsieur le Préfet au sénateur
non comme je vous l'ai indiqué je suis
pas assez un Brevin après l'incendie
en revanche je vous l'ai dit c'est vrai
que si on fait abstraction du contexte
qui était très contraint en termes
d'ordre public je pense que mon réflexe
aurait été aurait été de présenter comme
j'essaie de le faire au maximum en
allant en allant auprès des élus
je rappelle je suis retourné à
Saint-Brevin par la suite et j'ai
rencontré mais j'ai rencontré l'adjoint
à la sécurité pas pas le maire lui-même
je suis retourné à quelques jours après
à Saint-Brévin
non non après l'incendie des véhicules
après l'incendie des véhicules